- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are, and
how we got here. An exploration made
possible by the generosity of humans like
you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Sarah] So as we all know, mammalian
skin is decorated with diverse appendages
including our mammary glands, and hair
follicles with our associated sebaceous
glands, and apocrine glands which are
found in hair follicles mainly in the
axillary regions in humans. And also,
eccrine sweat glands which play an
extremely important regulation in human
thermoregulation. So the questions I'd
like to address in this talk are: Firstly,
"How did these organs evolve?" And
secondly, "Do they have a common
evolutionary origin?" For the most part,
skin has not left us with a fossil record.
And so, this makes it very difficult to
answer these types of evolutionary
questions. But one approach to addressing
these issues, is to ask whether the
development and genetics of these organs
can give us some clues to their evolution.
So during embryonic development, it turns
out that the very early stages in the
formation of mammary glands, hair
follicles, and sweat glands, are
morphologically very similar. So the
mammary gland develops from the ectoderm.
This is the outermost layer of the embryo
and it's diagrammed here in pink, and
underlying mesenchymal cells which is
shown as black dots. And the first sign of
glandular development is a localized
thickening in the ectoderm, which is
called a placode and this then buds down
into the mesenchyme and induces the
formation of a fat pad. After that, the
mammary sprout continues to grow downwards
and starts to branch and develops a lumen.
If we look at hair follicle development,
we find that this is also characterized
firstly by the formation of a localized
thickening in the ectoderm followed by
formation of a bud. And after that stage,
the development of hair follicles diverges
from the that of mammary glands.
The last organ to develop in embryonic
life out of these three is the eccrine
sweat glands which form around birth. And
these also form first through thickening
of the surface ectoderm, budding into the
mesenchyme and then further down growth,
which in this case involves curling of a
tube to form the gland and the development
of the lumen. Another thing that these
organs all have in common is that we know
that it's extremely important that the
cells of different types are able to
communicate with each other. So in each
case, the epithelial and mesenchymal cells
engage in extensive cross talk between
these different cell types. So this cross
talk is made possible by the secretion of
signaling factors from one cell that is
then received by another cell and cause
changes in this receiving cell that can
include changing its proliferation status
or its fate. Two of the really important
cell-cell signaling pathways that are
involved in early stages of appendage
development are the Wnt signaling pathway,
and the ectodysplasin or EDA signaling
pathway. In each case, these involves
secreted Wnt ligans, secreted ligans that
are received by a receptor. In the Wnt
pathway, the ligan is known as Wnt. So
this is made by another cell and it floats
out and then starts to interact with
receptors on the receiving cell. And this
causes a whole series of intracellular
changes that end up with the activation of
target gene expression and these genes
then can cause a change in fate of the
cell.
Ectodysplasin signaling, similarly
involves a secreted ligan, in this case
called EDA, and this interacts with its
receptor and causes a different set of
changes intracellularly. But these also
result in expression of target genes. So
it turns out, that Wnt signaling is
absolutely key for the formation of all of
these different appendages, if its absent,
they completely fail to form. And if you
over activate this pathway using genetic
tricks in mice, we see that you get extra
appendages forming. Downstream of Wnt
signaling, the ectodysplasin pathway is
activated. And this requires Wnt in order
to get started, but then takes over from
Wnt in further promoting the formation of
these organs. So both the similar
morphology and the similar molecular
pathways involved in the formation of
these diverse organs suggest that they may
have a common origin. If we look during
evolution, our ancient ancestors, the
sauropods, had, at least some of them,
were thought to have a glandular skin. And
this was selected for in the therapsids.
And these animals lacked scales, in fact,
and had completely glandular skin. And
people have argued that one of the
functions of this glandular skin was to
provide moisture through skin secretions
to the eggs of these creatures, which are
known to have been very thin-walled and
would likely have dehydrated otherwise.
The development of hair has been argued to
be possibly a specialization that could
have led to...that could have aided in the
delivery of glandular secretions to eggs.
So the mammals that exist today, fall into
several classes of which the Monotremes
still lay eggs and they lack nipples and
suckle their young via specialized hairs.
And these animals include the Spiny
Anteaters and Platypus. Whereas marsupials
do have nipples, but these "nipple
primordia" actually co-form hair follicles
and mammary glands during development as
I'll show you in a minute. The placental
animals which include ourselves have
developed hairless nipples. And these
probably facilitate the suckling of
newborns. So there is also some molecular
evidence for this kind of a scheme. So, it
was thought that the mucus secreting
surface epithelia make anti-microbial
enzymes as an important function of these
epithelia, and these include xanthine
oxidoreductase and lysozyme. And as glands
developed in order to more effectively
secrete these antimicrobials and
eventually forming mammary glands. At the
same time as this development or evolution
occurred, the gene in coding lysozyme
actually became duplicated. And one of the
copies evolved into the alpha lactalbumin
gene and this encodes an important
component of milk and is also involved in
the manufacture of lactose, another
important component of milk. It's also
been shown that xanthine oxidoreductase
has a secondary function in addition to
its antimicrobial properties. It's also
important in encasing fat droplets in milk
and allowing their secretion.
So, these enzymes seem to have adopted
additional functions that allow them to
help in milk production. Another piece of
evidence that...for a common origin for
mammary glands and hair follicles came, as
I already mentioned, from studies of
marsupial mammary development. So in
marsupials, the nipple develops, as I
mentioned already, from a thickening in
the ectoderm. And this elongates and
develops two types of sprouts, a primary
sprout and secondary buds. And these
secondary buds go on to form mammary
glands whereas the primary sprouts develop
into hair follicles with associated
sebaceous glands. So this is all happening
during the embryonic development of the
marsupial. And the last stage of
development, the nipple actually everts
and it retains these sebaceous glands and
of course the mammary glands, but the hair
follicles degenerate in most marsupials.
Although it is known that koala bears
actually have hair still emanating from
their nipples. So, this common development
of these different types of organs in the
same structure really provides support for
the idea that these things may have
co-evolved. So of course, the numbers and
locations of mammary glands have evolved
to fit the litter size and feeding
position. So in humans, we generally have
one baby and we have two mammary glands.
The babies are usually, we usually hold
our babies to our chest and that's where
the mammary glands are located.
By contrast, pigs have very large litters
with an average size of 10 and they have
12 to 14 nipples or tits. They tend to
feed in a lying position and their nipples
are located all along the side of their
body. Cattle, generally have a litter size
of one and only four nipples or tits. And
they feed standing up with the mammary
tits in an inguinal position. So, what are
the mechanisms that may have permitted
these adaptation of mammary gland numbers
and locations to fit the needs of these
species? So in many mammals, the embryonic
mammary glands actually form along a line
between the fore- and hindlimb buds in the
embryo and this is known as the milk line
or mammary line. And it gradually becomes
fragmented resulting in the formation of
mammary buds. And this is diagrammed for a
mouse embryo. We can see something very
similar in the rabbit embryo. And this is
a scanning electron microscopy that allows
us to actually visualize this raised
mammary ridge. And this can also be seen
in human embryos. So as I mentioned, the
Wnt signaling pathway plays key roles in
the initiation of mammary gland
development. So there's no mammary
development without this signal. And if we
over activate it, you can get extra
mammary glands. And we can visualize this
nicely by looking at one of the Wnt ligans
called Wnt10b, and here we're using a
technique called in situ hybridization
[sp] to look at where the Wnt10b mRNA is
being made and this appears as a reddish
brown stain.
So we can see the stains all along the
milk line and is elevated in the
developing mammary buds. And
interestingly, in mice which lack a
secreted inhibitor protein, which would be
expected to result in excess Wnt
signaling, we find that these developed
extra nipples and extra mammary glands. So
these findings suggest that changes in the
pattern of Wnt signaling activity could
underlie the adaption of mammary gland
location and number. So, like the mammary
gland, our hair and sweat gland formation
varies greatly between mammalian species,
but also, varies within species. So if we
think about humans, of course we have nice
long hair on our head and very short, fine
hairs over the rest of our body. But
within our species, that hair can vary
greatly in its texture and its thickness.
Our apocrine glands, as I mentioned, are
mostly axial and we have eccrine sweat
glands all over our body. By contrast, a
polar bear has hair that's of rather
similar length over most of its body, but
this hair is specially adapted and it has
a large air pockets that allow much better
thermoregulation for the polar bear in
cold conditions. It also, interestingly,
has apocrine glands on the soles of its
feet and leaves a scent trail with these.
And its eccrine glands are confined to the
soles of the feet unlike in humans.
Horses apparently completely lack eccrine
glands and instead they sweat by a
different mechanism that utilizes apocrine
glands which are located all over the body
of the horse. And when these are active
you get this lathering appearance that we
see for instance in race horses.
And the hair of the body is mostly...the
hair of the horse is mostly short but has
specialize appearances on their tail and
the mane where it's very long. So there's
an incredible amount of variation here.
For both hair follicles and eccrine sweat
glands, the ectodysplasin signaling
pathway plays various key roles at early
stages of development. And indeed, loss of
function of this pathway in humans leads
to syndromes where there is really an
absence of all these organs. More relevant
to evolution, though, it turns out that
there's a variant of the receptor for
ectodysplasin which is associated with
increased activity of this receptor. And
in Asian populations, this variant
receptor is specifically seen in people
who have thick, straight hair, and
increased numbers of eccrine sweat glands.
Particularly in the Lee and Han
populations, this variant is extremely
predominant. And this is illustrated here
using a...looking at Asian populations and
individuals who have either straight or
non-straight hair. And you can see that if
you have the 370A variant of EDAR, you're
much more likely to have straight hair.
Whereas individuals with non-straight
hair, have more or less equal chance of
having either that A or the V variant. And
we can model this in mice by genetically
replacing the V variant of the gene with
an A variant and this in mice, as well as
in humans, results in the formation of
thicker hair,
and also an increased number of sweat
glands. So, here we're looking at the foot
pad of a mouse, actually several mice, and
these are stained with blue stain to
reveal the glands. And you can see the
greatly increased numbers of these glands
in the A variant. So mutation of EDAR to a
more active form may underlie a subset of
human variation in hair thickness and
straightness, and sweat gland density. So
just to summarize what I've told you,
evidence from development, genetics and
evolutionary studies suggest that mammary
glands, sweat glands and hair follicles
may be derived from a common precursor.
The function of this precursor may have
been to hydrate and protect thin-walled
eggs and later developed nutritional
functions as well. Mammary gland evolution
preceded the birth of live young. And
mammary gland adaptation may have occurred
in part through altered control of Wnt
signaling. Whereas variation in hair
thickness and sweat gland density are
associated with altered ectodysplasin
signaling. Now, there's an awful lot that
we don't know. Some very straightforward
questions such as, "What controls the
formation of different types of appendages
in specific regions of the body?" "How and
why did human eccrine glands becomes
ubiquitous to over our body and
intermingled with hair follicles?" And
very straightforward questions like, "Why
is human scalp hair longer than body
hair?" And of interest to many men in the
audience, "Why do many human males lose
their hair in a particular pattern?"
And I'm sure you can think of many
additional questions that we really don't
know the answers to yet and would like to.
So just to reiterate, that in future
studies, because of the relative dearth of
fossil records for mammalian skin, these
types of developmental and molecular
approaches to skin evolution can be
particularly useful. And this is just my
lab who contributed to some of the work
that I showed you. And thank you for your
attention.
♪ [music] ♪